let me ask the ridiculous question what
do you think
we're talking about cops what do you
think uh is the best martial arts for
self-defense
for sure jiu-jitsu yeah wrestling right
i think
grappling i should say what judo as well
especially in a cold climate if you get
someone who's got like a
heavy winter jacket on my god like judo
is an incredible
plus concrete that's the worst
place to be with a heavy winter jacket
with a judo specialist
and you're standing up with them oh my
god but i think
grappling because in most self-defense
situations it usually
winds up with grappling you're
definitely better off though knowing
some striking
because there's nothing more terrifying
than when you go to take someone down
they actually have takedown skills
but they can fight and so they have
takedown defense
and they know how to fight and then you
don't know how to stand up like the
worst thing in the world seeing someone
like reaching who doesn't know how to
do striking and someone cracks you what
about all that
krav maga talk which is like you know
the whole line of argument that says
that jiu jitsu and wrestling and all
these sports
they fundamentally take you away from
the nature of violence
so they're just teaching you how to play
versus the reality of of um
violence that is involved in like a
self-defense situation
that is is a totally different set of
skills would be needed
in general the people that say that jiu
jitsu
or other martial arts don't they it's
more of a sport
and they don't really understand and
they don't really understand violence
in general the people that say that suck
yeah that's anybody who thinks like
someone's like you know hey man i'll
just bite you
i'm like are you gonna bite me okay do
you think i'm gonna bite you too
what do you think of that what if i
punch you in your [ __ ] face you think
you're still gonna bite me
when you can't even see yeah when you
you you barely even know you're alive
and i
choke you unconscious if someone's
really good at jiu jitsu
good luck stabbing them with your keys
you know you don't have a chance you
don't have a chance if someone's much
better you and they trip you
and get you on your back and then they
[ __ ] elbow you in your face and get a
head and arm choke on you
all that krav maga it's out the window
son you're
way better off learning what works on
train killers
like this whole idea that you're going
to poke some of the eye and then you're
going to kick him in the nuts and
like you're you're going through these
drills that yeah it's good to know
what to do if you run into someone who
doesn't know how to fight
it's way better to know what to do to
someone who knows how to fight
that's the best thing learn how to fight
against people who know how to fight
like all that practice self-defense and
they're gonna it's gonna come at you
with a knife you're gonna grab the wrist
and do that
like it's good to know self-defense
but it's much more important to
understand martial arts
comprehensively when you understand
martial arts comprehensively
like there's no crop i shouldn't say
there's no krav maga guys but it's
it would be shocking if a krav maga guy
and a mixed martial arts guy had a fight
and the mixed martial arts guy was a
trained killer all around
didn't [ __ ] that guy up that's that's
what i would expect would happen
i would i would i would not think that
some guy who
has a little bit of this and a little
bit of that and prepares for the streets
is going to be able to handle a person
who trains with killers
on a day-to-day basis who rolls with jiu
jitsu black belts
who trains with muay thai champions like
here
the best martial arts of the martial
arts that work on martial artists
not the martial arts that work on
untrained people
you